[Music]
what's going on guys this is our first
show in a while it's good to be back and
I'm so excited to be back with one of my
favorite segments here at screen junkies
movie science with one of my favorite
human beings the kind generous and
learning dr. Clifford V Johnson
dr. Johnson great to have you back it's
great to be back thanks for having me oh
of course you always come in and class
up the joint
first off I want to ask you about you of
a book that you've written not just
written I've been drawing it as well
there's actually been a labor of love
for many years it's a graphic book it's
a nonfiction book about science but it's
a graphic book it's like a graphic novel
that's making science more accessible
yeah it's called the dialogues
conversations about the nature of the
universe ah tremendous not only are you
a professor at USC a published author
but you also are a science advisor on
movies and TV shows including the
awesome Thor Ragnarok yeah Wow let's
jump into it so one of the coolest parts
of Asgard and the world that they've
established is the Bifrost how they
travel to different worlds different
realms
what's the Bifrost like literally in
scientific terms in a wormhole what what
is it
well I think you're on the right track
there it's clearly some sort of device
that allows you to move extraordinary
distances through the universe in a very
short amount of time the longest
escalator in the universe
the longest but also the shortest
because it does it really quickly so is
it like closer to a wormhole or is it
closer to like getting beamed up in Star
Trek
that's a good question my
rationalization of it is that it is
wormhole like but it has some properties
of something like a transporter you
still sort of see that beam that comes
down is it where but where's it coming
down from is it really stretching across
space and time like that no I actually
think it is going through some sort of
tunnel which a wormhole is thor ragnarok
taught me a very interest
term doctor I would like to ask you
about the devil's anus ah yes
what is the devil's anus as far as I
gather from what's going on on that
planet they've used it as a as a as a
friendly term for what seems to be one
of the largest and most violent wormhole
entrances hovering just above the
surface of the planet how is the devil's
anus formed you're not given any detail
in the film as to how things came that
way but you have this planet and there's
lots of entrances of wormholes that
stuff's falling out of them from
elsewhere in the universe or some sort
of nexus of stuff where lots of
wormholes connect and that's sort of
interesting and so kind of like a
freeway interchange yeah like a freeway
interchange but also it's also sort of a
parking lot for a lot of stuff that
comes out in a way yeah that sounds like
terrible traffic yes it's not made clear
whether that was a natural occurrence or
whether that is something that some
extraordinarily powerful being or
civilization has engineered so I think
you get to decide which but it's
certainly clear that there's there's a
lot of interesting opportunities for
stuff to come through that may be
interesting and so it makes sense then
to come and set up camp there and just
just exploit all that stuff that's
falling in and occasionally you get
interesting creatures that can be or
gladiators and things like that
what is a collapsing neutron star inside
an einstein-rosen bridge well an
einstein-rosen bridge is an example of a
kind of wormhole that connects to
distant parts of space sort of like a
shortcut the old analogy that's used
which we've seen in any number of films
is that you know you have a piece of
paper and you know there's one bit of
space and a little bit of space and then
you make a hole to make a hole and you
fold it together and now they're right
next to each other how many times has
that been used Ison Rosen bridge there
are many other kinds of wormhole but
that's the one that has the most fame
play in popular culture because Einstein
is attached to the name in the scenario
that is in the film is that the
different kinds of wormhole that you see
the ends of the wormhole is connecting
that end to some other end so depending
upon what's at the other end of the
wormhole or in the interior of the
wormhole it has certain properties and
so I think what's going on in that
particular one is that there's a neutron
star which is a very active kind of star
probably rotating really fast maybe very
magnetic yeah so it has a lot of
electromagnetic activity which you're
seeing the signs of the edge of that
wormhole and so when our scientist Bruce
Banner looks at it he recognizes that
it's that kind of wormhole with that
sort of activity who's smarter dr. Bruce
Banner or dr. Clifford V Johnson well
he's probably had a much longer career
he has seven PhD so we're done he wins
in the movie search her the demon had a
giant sword that he was going to destroy
Asgard with can you destroy a planet by
stabbing it with a sword big enough sold
describe the type of sword that one
would need to destroy Earth well
actually scenarios like that have
happened to the earth before what stay
with me so like a space creature
attacked earth with a with a blunt
object it wasn't really a space creature
but in the early years of the formation
of the solar system when the earth was
still young there's a lot of evidence
that something did smash into the earth
and a big chunk of it came off and
that's what the Moon actually is the
moon was a piece of the earth uh-huh due
to a big thing smashing into the earth
and smashing a piece off so it's a
little bit like your sword scenario yeah
like this sword or like a hammer yeah
Thor's hammer brought it back around
nicely done
Thor's hammer he uses that thing like a
helicopter
yes how does that work
I spin it really fast and it would pull
me off the ground up into the air and I
would fly yeah we don't really know
what's in that hammer I think it's more
than just a piece of very dense material
some of the heaviest matter that we know
of in the universe comes from the core
of dead stars so so I I suggested they
may they may throw that in and I think
there's a line in there where indeed
Thor mentions that about the origin of
the hammer but unique was made from this
special metal from the heart of a dying
star
the hammer has to be so heavy that like
if you get something that's that heavy
and then you let go could that pull you
out mmm I think that's not gonna work
well if I think about it yes nothing the
work the mass and the force yeah seems
great they'll just know you've got some
good terms there conservation of
momentum is gonna mess you up some means
by which something goes in the opposite
direction in order to propel him forward
there's no evidence that thought is
producing any exhaust as he flies
depends on what a Thor eat for lunch
exactly what I'm talking about
Yeah right so maybe he does maybe it's
just not talked about wait yeah okay
that's Guardian Manas
so you're saying it's possible that
every time Thor spins his hammer and
flies he is releasing massive god-like
farts
I said exhaust spoiler alert Matt Damon
had a cameo I'm wondering if his
character was actually his character
from interstellar and he was flung into
a black hole and somehow wound up on
Asgard where in order to survive he had
to become an actor and weird plays
directed by odin slash Loki that's
utterly brilliant and you know he can
get around he knows how to get around
these various places because he's also
the talented mr. Ripley all movies exist
in the same reality and they all have
Matt Damon in them in some way so we're
not just talking Thor there was a lot of
Hulk in the movie Oh is a little help
yeah
Hulk
got his powers from gamma radiation if I
got struck by gamma rays in real life
what would happen to me probably
depending on how much exposure you had
yeah not that you properly read you
probably get ill these are high-energy
electromagnetic waves that when they hit
the stuff that makes you up the atoms
and molecules they tend to just damage
them I'd be sick but what would happen
dr. Clifford V Johnson if you made me
angry well I'd probably feel really bad
that I made you angry because you're
sick so I wouldn't Hulk out I'd just be
like sick and angry just be sick and
angry getting hit by gamma rays would
suck yeah oh it came to me here it is
apparently I'm worthy enough to lift the
hammer Panther you are I knew you had it
in you thanks doc Oh doctor I want to
thank you for coming in here and
wielding a mighty hammer of knowledge
it's a pleasure thanks for having me Oh
always a pleasure what are some of the
movies that you want to see the science
broken down for are there any other
pressing MCU science questions you'd
like us to pose to dr. Clifford V
Johnson let us know in the comments
section below we want to know I want to
thank our good friend dr. Clifford B
Johnson once again pick up his book the
dialogues and I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
[Music]